- [Voiceover] Consider
the formula P is equal to
W divided by T where P represents power,
W represents work and has units of Joules
and Joules can be expressed as kilograms
times meters squared
per seconds squared and
T represents time and
has units of seconds.
And when you get to physics
class you'll get very familiar
with things like Joules
which can be represented
as kilograms times meters squared
per seconds squared and things like power.
But here we're going
to learn to manipulate
these units so that they make sense.
So it says select an appropriate
measurement unit for power.
And what we've seen multiple times in our
mathematical careers is that
on a certain level you can
manipulate units in a lot of the same ways
that you would manipulate
variables or numbers.
So if power is equal
to work divided by time
we could also say that the units for power
are going to be the units for work
divided by the units for time.
So the units for work...the units
for work right over here is Joules.
And so we could write it's going to be
Joules per and then the
unit for time is seconds.
So you might want to say
it's Joules per second.
But we don't see Joules per
second as a choice here,
so we probably want to expand out Joules
as being kilogram meters squared
per seconds squared so lets do that.
So this is going to be equal to Joules
we can re-write as kilogram
times meters squared over
seconds squared and we are going
to divide all of that by seconds.
And so what's that going to be?
Well we could re-write this,
this is going to be kilograms
(and I'm intentionally trying
not to skip any steps),
kilograms times meters
squared per seconds squared
and dividing by seconds
is the same thing as
multiplying by 1 over seconds.
So times 1 over seconds and
so if we treat these units
the way that we might
treat things like variables
this would be equal to, in the numerator,
we would have kilogram
times meters squared
or kilogram times square meters
over the denominator
you have seconds squared
times seconds, you have
seconds to the third power.
So a unit for power, one way
to express the units for power,
could be kilogram meters
squared per second cubed.
And we see that this is this first choice
kilograms meters squared
per seconds cubed.